- [Voiceover] If x and y are integers,
seven is less than y is less than 16,
and x over y is equal to 2/5,
how many possible values are there for x?
So x and y have to be integers,
and y is greater than
seven and less than 16.
So let's, before we even
think about this constraint
right over here and this constraint,
if we just had this
constraint right over here,
what are the possible values for y?
Well, y is an integer greater than seven,
so let's see, it would
be eight, nine, 10, 11,
12, 13, 14, 15,
and it can't be equal to 16
so we'll stop right over here.
So just with that constraint,
here are all our candidate ys.
Now they're saying x
over y is equal to 2/5,
or another, let me just rewrite that.
So they're saying x
over y is equal to 2/5,
or if you multiply both sides by y,
you get x is equal to 2/5y.
Now, if x is equal to 2/5y,
so over here you would
have eight times 2/5.
So let me write this down.
So these are our possible ys,
and then our possible xs,
eight times 2/5.
Now is this thing right over
here going to be an integer?
Remember, x and y need to be integers.
Well no, eight isn't divisible by five.
Eight times two is 16, 16
isn't divisible by five.
And so this is not going to be an integer.
Is nine times 2/5, is that
going to be an integer?
No, nine isn't divisible by five.
I think you start to see a pattern here.
10 times 2/5, is that
going to be an integer?
Sure!
10 is divisible by five.
10 divided by five is two,
10 divided by five is two, times two,
this is equal to four.
So this is a possible value for x,
and frankly this is a possible value,
this is a possible value for y,
if we assume that they
both have to be integers.
And so we don't have to test all of these,
we just say,
"Look, which of these are
also divisible by five?"
Well, 10 is divisible by five,
and 15 is divisible by five.
None of these other ones
are divisible by five.
So if y is 15,
we don't even have to
know what the value is,
we could say x is going
to be 15 times 2/5,
which is 15 divided by five is three,
times two which is six.
So there are two possible values,
there are two possible values for x.